اعدادات الذخائر العنقوديه الامريكيه قالت
سفاره الروسيه في واشنطن ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لن تلتزم باي قيود عند
استخدامها القنابل العنقوديه وعند اختيار
الاهداف ارجعت السفاره السبب الى مسمته
حاله الياس التي تعيشها كييف جراء الخسائر
الفادحه وعدم تحقيق نجاح على الجبهه اضافت
السفاره الروسيه انها لن تتوقع عدد
الضحايا المدنيين عندما يبدا من سمتهم
مجرمي كاف باستخدام الذخائر العنقوديه
الامريكيه ووصفت السفاره تصريحات
المسؤولين الامريكيين بشان ما سموه
استخدام اوكرانيا الحذر للذخائر العنقوديه
بالمحاوله الخرقاء لتبرير اعمالهم
والاستفزازيه
وكان قائد عمليات القوات المشتركه في
المحور الجنوبي الاوكراني
قال ان اوكرانيا تسلمت قنابل عنقوديه من
واشنطن مؤكدا على قوه هذا السلاح واهميته
واضاف ان القنابل العنقوديه ستعطي افضليه
للقوات الاوكرانيه
وستغير شكل المعركه كما قال